San Diego comic-con 2018 and I'm here
with Miles Morales and Peter Parker
they have real names that are shameik
Moore and Jake Johnson but you will no
longer refer to them by those names by
the time this interview is done we are
also going to fling webs at you
gentlemen please was mine okay thank you
really what what I want to know is when
I when I saw the trailer for spider-man
into the spider verse I'm like I've
never seen anything like this before and
I've watched a lot of animated films or
watch a lot of superhero films mhm I
didn't this is mind-blowing to me and
the technology involved but how did they
pitch that to you guys
when it when they brought you into it
how did they describe what they saw the
project being I wasn't really pitched if
if I could be honest yeah it was like
you know spider-man Miles Morales okay
cool
for me tapes and I'm gonna hope for the
best that's I think would you to meet to
me when you get that call you're like Oh
spider-man they don't even they don't
have a finish I got an email from Phil
Lord years a couple years ago that said
he was writing this and he was thinking
about me for Peter Parker but he would
want me I would obviously have to
audition for it and was this something I
was interested in and obviously like you
said the answer is yes but then once we
got in they started talking about the
animation and how they saw it yeah and
it just makes you more excited right
exactly so you're like oh cool and it's
gonna look great yeah and I always like
working with a creative who has a clear
vision yeah as opposed to like oh we'll
just put it together and then we'll test
it and see what we've got
yeah these guys knew what they wanted to
make from the start so it's been a real
pleasure jumping in so much depends on
the answer to this next question yeah
she may go ahead did you record the
voiceover for the movie a bunch of times
and it was it together was it where you
did they do the thing where you're kind
of in the same room so you can react to
each other or was it completely separate
we've done separate and we've done
together oh good together is the best
together is the best because you
actually I got to figure out you know I
reading as Peter Parker so I'm reading
the material and I'm trying to do it as
best as they wanted but I'm hearing
about miles and I'm doing scenes with
miles yeah I can tell like all right so
Peters annoyed he's mad but it's
different when all of a sudden shamekh
comes in and brings his energy
yeah and we're facing each other and I
see like and we're a lot we do improvise
a little bit we add and we're allowed to
try to like make each other laugh or get
mad so you start feeling like oh so
that's miles so it's no longer on a
script right now I'm Peter that's miles
and we're in it right now yeah that's
when in kids as an actor at least for me
it gets really fun yes I heard this is
random but I heard Gary Busey say that
he memorizes lines just by reading them
emotionless getting them in his head but
then getting with the other actor to let
the scene open up and let it be what
it's gonna become that's the first time
Gary Busey's been quoted weird right and
that's the thing like it exactly what I
do I don't I sit in my head but then
that first rehearsal I always went to
you're like setting up lights I always
try to find the other actor and it'll be
like hey you want to run these a couple
times because you're not gonna really
know it until you hear how the other
person says it and then you remember
yours well and this is a pretty
different version of spider-man because
we've never seen Miles Morales before
and so you're the dude and I see it in
your eyes like yes I am ready for this
responses yes I am ready for this
responsibility why is it time like why
is why now
that's devant and you know this one
that's past mean that's a deeper
question you know but I am I think is
it's time for the movie to come out and
it's time for it's time for some
positive role models for the youth in
general and I think that's why it's time
I think that's why Sony and Marvel are
like you know what let's go ahead and do
this animation let's go ahead and bring
light to Miles Morales let's help the
world let's
think about it like that like that
they're so pumped yeah the minute you
see Miles Morales everybody's like yes
they heard my prayers finally so cool
yes well it's so kind of as a result of
that you're Peter Parker you're Peter
Parker but also you're gonna like
different Peter Parker that's right
may I say a little schlubby and you're
like a mentor is Peter Parker at 40 its
Peter Parker when he's been spider-man
for a long time and he doesn't know if
he still loves it he doesn't know what
it means to be spider-man
the allure of it all came and went and
then he's left with deal and what it
actually means to be spider-man and what
that means in terms of your life right
what it really means to be spider-man
and then he's put in a situation where
he meets somebody who needs help and to
become spider-man but Peter Parker is
not a teacher he's spider-man so it's
being something in him he's getting
pulled but then he sees something
special in this kid and that's the any
other movie I think mm-hmm you ever find
yourself like kind of taking that role
on a mentor with other performers that
haven't been through as many things as
you have yes whenever you're on set with
somebody and you realize somebody's good
but they're a little bit new to the game
you just do little tweaks because you
also know if I help you relax in this
moment with the camera and you our scene
is going to be better
mmm and I have had people the elder
statesman who are still doing it to me
yeah so I'll be on set and somebody will
say something and I'm like I'm writing
that down
that really helps like even today we
both learned from Gary Busey you learned
from him second hand that's right so
really you learn from me that is the
only time that will ever happen in my
life and it felt really good okay can
you come up with an like a specific
instance of when someone has schooled
you in a really loving way yeah I can
Jon Hamm and I just did
the movie tag together and we were doing
press one of the things the press was we
were crashing a wedding and so we were
sitting outside of this bar in Miami and
the wedding was happening and the people
at the wedding were getting out of hand
with alcohol and I thought this is a
promotional move that could get out of
hand because you got Jeremy Renner Meade
I mean that homes crashing a wedding and
I go you got one weird uncle who takes
us the wrong way
we're getting beaten up at this wedding
and I was like asking cause I don't know
if we do this maybe we don't do then Jon
Hamm said it's 90 seconds of your life
can you do this for 90 seconds you could
probably do just about anything for 90
seconds so do it and I took that advice
I did the 90 seconds the event worked
the promotion worked and I was really
glad I just zipped my lips and did 90
seconds and as a result I also am
convinced that you and John Hamre also
rivals in real life like you were in tag
so I just nailed you nailed it that's
acting interview I have to have people
remind me that it's just a movie but
like this is your fan base so get ready
he's my rival um is Spider Man into the
spider-verse going to be opening up the
spider-man universe in a different way
is that something that you guys can
speak to because I know that people are
like questions are a poppin there's a
reference in the trailer how many Spider
Men are there save it for Comic Con you
say what's Comic Con you gotta remember
that line you know why why because we
know a Comic Con day do you get what I'm
saying
nope all right well you gotta watch the
movie mystery is alive smarter man into
the spider verse and I sent like a whole
new thing on the horizon
look this is we're opening it up we're
like allowing new versions of this story
to be told I think it could very
possibly be it's very possible but on
this year's Christmas you know we will
see this movie in your and
your questions will be answered I think
if everybody sees it and likes it it
might help answer more questions mm-hmm
there we go okay so see it and like it
and that way they'll tell all your
friends
[Music]